hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game between Vladislav Artemyev and
Hikaru Nakamura from the 2019 edition of
the Gibraltar chess festival we already
seen a couple of nice games by Artemyev
as he had quite an outstanding result in
both of the world blitz and the world
rapid 2018 championship in the blitz
section he won't sixth place and in the
rapid section
he got third place so really outstanding
results but this is classical chess so
it's always interesting how he will fare
against the top elites like Hikaru
Nakamura
now as the dates of Gibraltar just
Festival and the Tata Steel have
collided a bit we are only starting the
coverage at around 7 and we do have a
couple of nice photos not from round 7
as Nikki decided to take her rest today
but we do have a nice photo of Nakamura
here it's from round 6 where he has the
white pieces but just so you get you
know into the mood of the tournament and
also here we have a very nice photo of
Chucky there you can see he is most
likely contemplating his next brilliancy
or you know he could he could be doing
anything but a very nice photo now
getting back to the game Artemia opens
with nice to f3 the righty opening we
have Knight f6 g3 and d5 so we have
Bishop to g2 and now II 6 we have the
Yugoslavia reaction of the Kings Indian
attack
we have castles by artemyev and now
Bishop to e7 c4 challenging the center
we have castles by Nakamura b3 not
preparing to fianchetto the other bishop
as well
c5 grabbing more space and now Bishop to
b2 nice to see 6 Nakamura continues
developing we have III and now b6
Nakamura will also be in cat of his
light square bishop nice to see 3 and
now D captures on c4 we have B captures
on c4 and now Bishop the b7 and this has
all been played before so far this is a
pretty much all standard theory here
Queen e2 and here in 2017
Fabiano car wanna play this position
against LaVon Arlen Arlen played Queen
to c7 here and he was able to win that
game against Caruana in the st. Louis
blitz tournament but here Nakamura goes
roped the c8 so we have a different line
but still not a new position rook 8 d1
preparing to put the D pawn Quintus e7
getting the Queen Arthur the D file also
connecting rooks
and now comes the Knights the e1 prepare
and making room for the f4 pawn so it
can be pushed forward and this is where
we meet the new move so far rook F to d8
has been played here a six has been
played here Queen B 8 has been played
here nice to a5 offering a trade of
light square bishop has been tried here
but Nakamura goes 498 he wants the
Reedman over the Knights to d6 and okay
we have f4 Knight to d6 and now Knight
back to f3 as DF pawn has now moved from
f2 to f4 we have a 6 by Nakamura and now
a for not allowing b5 we have f5 by
nakamura and now comes b3 and as usual
in these kinds of positions were you
will have a lot of young care of bishops
it so it's really a long positional
struggle where everyone just wants to
grab more space Bishop to f6 a much more
useful Square for the bishop and now h3
and we have night the b4 as the pawn is
now on a 4 and C for the night has a
very nice outpost and unbel
I can't really be kicked away from there
and also it puts pressure on the d3 pawn
and here g4 is played Artemia wants to
open up the G file put the King to h1 or
h2 put the rooks on the G file and
create an attack against a Kimura skin
we have g6 by Nakamura and now you could
push g5 if that's the kind of game you
want to play but here Artemia who put
more pressure
he puts place efore attacks DF 5 pawn
but also there's the threat of a 5 so
what do you play here ok f captures on
e4 it's played d captures on e4 and now
it's a really
nice position for you to just look at
and maybe maybe decide how you would
deal with this position with the black
pieces as a 5 is definitely a threat so
what do you play here even pause the
video and you know try to try to figure
out how to go about this position if you
did it
congratulation says you know not
everyone is eager to defend but the best
idea here is to prevent e5 bishops to d4
check and now white will just have to
move the King King h2 and there is no
more threat of losing the piece and you
will just continue your game if you
capture then after pawn captures you are
even threatening d3 you don't want to
allow that so you would have to capture
here but after Queen c5 pinning the rook
now even Queen f2 rook captures you
force the Queen to move away from the
defense of the row Queen captures Queen
captures and after King H 1 you can go
Knight d3 now and it's just a very very
nice position for black now the queen is
the tag the bishop is attacked just a
very nice position the knight is
controlling f7 so no Queen f7 is
possible
black will just be better here so after
this D captures only for Bishop b4 check
would have been the best idea for for
Hikaru but he went Knight captures on e4
and I know what you're thinking what
sorcery is this the the e4 square is
covered two times by the Queen and by
the knight but this is what Nakamura
meant the bishop will be also attacking
the bishop on b2 so we have Knight
captures on e4 by Artemyev and now
Bishop captures on b2 and indeed if
Queen captures and Bishop captures
Nakamura would have been perfectly fine
here but instead artemyev went Knight
eg5 leaving the option of Queen captures
on b2 hanging but also threatening
Knight captures an d 6 which would fork
the rook and the Queen so what do you do
here now you don't really have the time
to save the bishop with this check now
because white will simply capture it and
after pawn captures Bishop captures
Queen captures and now Queen captures a
sex with check white will have a winning
position here after King moves you can
capture on d4 rook is coming to d7 f5 is
coming everything just falls apart for
black
so after night eg5 first nakamura
decided to remove the defender of the d4
square which is the f3 night so a Bishop
captures on f3 first rook captures on f3
and now comes a Bishop to b4 check now
there is no night to capture the bishop
came to h1 and here what do you play
here
Mora played rook CT 8 but just in case
you're wondering for example rook
captures on f4 isn't possible because
the e6 pawn is hanging now you would
just capture it and after King moves
rook captures on f4 and you cannot
recapture because the rook on c8 is now
hanging in capture screen captures and
you're lost here 15 G 796 check you even
lose the Queen
so after king h1 rook CT 8 is played not
allowing this rook to stay and see it as
a target but also putting some defense
to the e6 pawn but Artemyev doesn't mind
we have Knight captures an e6 now
attacking the Queen and the rook but
it's not all that terrible as if you
move the knight you're going to lose
your undefended Queen and e2 so here
there are a couple of moves is Nakamura
could play she goes I'm like rook to f6
but he decides to go for Queen to c6 now
there is a double attack against
artemius knight on f6 on e sense but
also Nakamura is pressuring the a4 pawn
so we have 8th f5 defending the knight
and now Queen captures on a4 Nakamura
grabs the pawn and if he will be able to
defend this position then he does have a
lot of points here that he can push on
the Queen side and here we have F cap
you still cannot capture as you will
lose your queen here so we have pawn
captures on g6 now the threat is rook
captures on a fait with check then this
rook would have to capture you would not
be pinned anymore and you would snatch
both rooks so rook captures on f3 and
now an in-between move at swishing
through if you will G captures on h7
with check King to h8 much safer than
capturing as this dark square bishop
controls this diagonal and now comes a
bishop captures an f3 and this is really
the critical moment of the game
Nakamura
and not having all that many choices
here White's threat is pretty much
simple the white ones the capture on d4
and after the bishop is eliminated play
Queen e5 check and Queen g7 checkmate it
there's very little black can do to
prevent this even capturing this pawn I
mean you could have captured it even
before but here it will just run into
the same idea it's a forced mate
queening forecheck King has to move back
now you eliminate the bishop on capture
screen captures and now wherever you go
it will be it will be checkmate for
example here in Queen g7 will be
checkmate
but there was one move after this Bishop
to f3 that Nakamura could have tried as
the threat is rook captures on d4 so
again feel free to pause the video as we
will be pausing a video a few more times
and try to find this interesting move
black could have played to prevent rook
captures on d4 not very often do I ask
you to try and defend the position but
it's it's an interesting move
what Nakamura could have tried here is
Knight to d3 a very sneaky move now you
cannot capture as the knight is blocking
the path here and here you would have to
play Queen captures and allow row
characters on e6 and here maybe black
could you know consolidate maybe start
pushing his own PI spawns on the Queen
side what would still be better but
there would be some chances and on the
other hand if Luke captures then black
even gets the upper hand after Queen
captures on c4 attacking the knight on
e6 twice now and after rook capture Sun
before offering the Queen trait and now
you capture Queen captures the Bishop
captures and seek after Sundy for your
knight is attacked here and now you can
try try different things you could try
defending the knight but then you get b5
and the D pawn starts marching forward
you will lose the night either way so
it's better to just capture here and
then allow this a double attack rook to
e4 attacking the knight and the bishop
now after the whatever you decide to do
best especial captures now a rueful
capture here and you will have this
position where black has a rook and the
pawn when white has a bishop and three
pawns but those this pawn
we lost so black will have black will
have a better position hard to say if
black would be able to win this but you
know you could play it so our very
interesting move this after Bishop to f3
Knight to d3 Nakamura however tried a
different approach he played a Knight to
c6 now saying okay you can capture here
but I'm just gonna capture with the pawn
and my knight cover c5 so no Queen e5
checks will be possible but this move
just wanders the game so feel free to
pause the video again and try to find
what our team you've played after which
Nakamura simply resigned the game I will
give you a couple of seconds for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
player and for those who've just one
enjoyed show now here are Timmy played
Knight captures on c5 and the threat is
obvious Queen captures rook is the
threat but also Knight captures Queen is
the threat so if the well obvious route
capture Sonny to happens then we get
Knight captures on a4 and now your rook
is under attacked and under attack and
your knight and c6 is under attack and
the problem is if you defend the night
then the knight is also the defender of
the d4 Bishop simply captures captures
and captures white is up for now two
points and a full night so are
completely winning position and other
than that there's no way to protect your
queen and for somehow to protect this
rook on e8 so black is here without a
move and it was in this position and
move 31 that Hikaru Nakamura resigned
the game but yeah a beautiful game and
instead of this knight c6 a very very
sneaky and interesting 93 could have
could have been attempted but yeah
Knight captures on c5 and a wonderful
victory by vladislav Artemia which puts
him in the lead in this tournament there
you can see this is rank after round 7
Vladislav Artemyev in so lead with six
points then we have a whole lot of
people with five and a half points now
in Navarre O'Neill's grand alias arc
adonai - Levon Aronian nikita v-cube of
even charge
Rasmus Swain Alcuin lien maxima Sheila
grab you young ye key relax Alex & Co
Moxie Matlock of Mario mucho also very
highly ranked lovely bauble Wesley so
Michael Adam self Mamedov Jose Fernando
cuenca Jimenez Pamela Leonov Bhaskar
inaudible Hikaru Nakamura in 22nd place
after losing this game to artemiev but
as you can see he has 5 points so if he
won this game against ur team if he
would actually be in so lead so you know
that's just how it is
yeah I bombed on Daniel Derek
that's and Lucas D and the Maxima guards
in 25th place so these are the top 25
players and it's an extremely strong
tournament in the in the Gibraltar 2019
edition I believe there are over 100
grand masters so you know sharing any
place here is is excellent especially
being in the top 25 after after seven
rounds avid yeah still a lot more games
to go in this tournament it will be
interesting and we'll see will will
Hikaru once again be able to win it I
believe he wanted three times so far and
I think they even gave him some special
reward like the third time he wanted he
he received some special watch and there
was even a joke that if he comes next
year and he wants it to that he was they
will even give him a car alongside with
the reward but I'm pretty sure they were
joking about that but you never know sir
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and that you enjoyed the few photos
especially the the one with Yvonne shook
those were taken by Nicky Riga if you
enjoy some Chas photos do be sure to
follow her on her social media I will
add some links in the description below
I would like to thank Robert kun Robert
Moore even invention Thomas Ravello and
Pearman automat for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content and the photos of you wondering
yes the subscribers video is coming it's
just taking a bit longer so thank you
all and I will
soon